we're going to keep the focus on
i guess the racial politics of the day
because we have more from colbert and
aoc and i'm sorry you know there's a lot
of important things we can talk about
but making fun of aoc is fun it's fun
and um look i i i i try not to be
overtly just like ha ha let's mock her
for the sake of mocking her yo she went
on stephen colbert's show to millions of
people
strung together a bunch of history words
that made no sense
with a straight face
and i'm just it's laughably absurd that
she would be asked if she would be
president after saying something so
nonsensical but you know sheamus pointed
out it's a chad move to go on tv and
just be like
yeah you know um abraham lincoln yeah he
was a capricorn and uh uh uh you know
winston churchill they were cousins oh
wow that's crazy yeah separate and
you're it's like making like stephen
cole is like will you be my president
wow i didn't know that yeah yeah yeah
joe navarre yeah yeah yeah that's
lincoln's mom that's pretty cool for
sure let me play you this clip don't
know john of arc was noah's wife haven't
you seen those right yeah yeah
let me play this clip for you because
it's going to make you laugh
so colbert basically answers a ton of
questions for aoc on her behalf and then
she says this what action would you like
to see the congress take well i think uh
history really informs the law you turn
this up does it inform you let me start
our
proportion can you up in the turn to the
people and big in the volume
well i think uh history really informs a
lot um and it gives us lessons here
because this is not the first time that
this has happened uh in the 1800s the
supreme court was taken over
by the confederate south and was
starting to
rule in ways that limited abraham
lincoln for example in in the dred scott
ruling they ruled that black americans
are not and can never be full citizens
united states and what did abraham
lincoln do he signed the emancipation
proclamation
i thought she was going to say he packed
the
court during
franklin delano roosevelt yo she just
strung a bunch of words together all
right let me break it down for you
everybody
the supreme court was not taken over by
the confederacy because the confederacy
was not a part of the union they did not
rule in ways that impeded abraham
lincoln because abraham lincoln became
president after secession dred scott was
one thing she got right a ruling that
said citizenship was not for descendants
for people of african descent but dred
scott happened four years before abraham
lincoln became president and abraham
lincoln did not issue the emancipation
proclamation in response to dred scott
the emancipation proclamation was issued
two years after he became president six
years after dred scott and has nothing
to do with citizenship at all it was the
14th amendment that came about after the
civil war that answered the question of
citizenship yo aoc went on colbert and
just said a bunch of civil era words at
the same time with confidence i gotta
admit sheamus you're right it's chad
mega chad she's like when abraham
lincoln first signed roe v wade into law
it was to free women from slavery oh my
god because the confederates had invaded
the supreme court and abraham lincoln
had no choice but to build an ark and
take two of each animal
yeah what i think she met was
before the civil war the south had
people that were becoming supreme court
justices and they were like leaning
towards the southern states their
beliefs and then when she said but then
and then they challenged abraham lincoln
what she meant was they challenged the
ideas that abraham lincoln came to
embody later
uh but she just messed it all up right i
mean if that's what she meant which is i
the only thing i can imagine she meant
you can she's just wrong you can imagine
anything you want what she said was a
string of 1860s related words
that didn't actually fit together i mean
that was written by a.i
that was written by ai she wrote
she wrote roe v wade civil war and then
it struck that together but i'm so
impressed with the way she delivered it
with the utmost confidence yes yeah
that's pretty chad and she started off
with history in in in forms she's
letting everyone know i know that's just
through the forums and it gives a bunch
of like strange history i i just that
i was watching this and i was just like
i'm like the confederacy hadn't had
invaded the supreme court where impeding
lincoln i was like how are they impeding
lincoln he wasn't even president even if
her point was that southern
southern sympathetic justices were on
the court
they could not have in any way impeded
uh abraham lincoln because he wasn't
even president until after several
states had already seceded and said that
they were no longer part of the union
they and and there was a question before
he was even president as to whether
there would be military intervention to
stop session now granted fair point
abraham lincoln won the election and
then they were like all right that's it
we're out yeah
and then several months later several
states secede and then lincoln becomes
president he's like i don't recognize
any of this and things started to
escalate from there but had nothing to
do with the supreme court granted he did
try to go after a justice it's just when
i heard this and she was like dred scott
said that you know
black people weren't citizens so abraham
lincoln what did he do he issued the
emancipation proclamation i'm like those
two things are unrelated to each other
when judge dredd scott
decided
not ready these these people offend me
these these are the black bourgeoisie
elite that are more interested in
diversity equity and inclusion full
politics than they are the american
people and later in this clip i think
she said something along the lines when
they ask her about running for president
i'm interested in helping the american
people no she's not i mean she's a
complete puppet she's a prop she's uh
she's an actress and she doesn't need to
know history because the entire
mainstream media apparatus
is is her backstop i'll tell you what
she is you've got you guys got to watch
the new beavers and butthead has anybody
here seen the new beeps and just a clip
everybody's sharing the white privilege
clip but i got a minor minor spoiler for
you guys it's not it's not a story
spoiler um but it's kind of but i have
to say it
many of you may have seen it but there's
a point at which bibs and butthead for
some reason can't see
and so they're just like waving their
arms around with their eyes pointing in
the wrong directions both of them that's
aoc yeah it's not a puppet it's that she
like
was sitting in a room one day and
someone was like dude like dred scott
was like really bad because the us
government like these supreme court
people were like you're not a citizen
yeah the supreme court's illegitimate
they've been illegitimate she's like
yeah
and then someone's like but bro that
emancipation proclamation right and she
goes yeah and then she sits on the couch
she goes well tread scrat and the
emancipation it's like some stoner dude
just said a bunch of random stuff it's
no one look if she was a puppet she'd
been given a cue card that would have
said something more coherent
you sit here right you take your seat
you explain dred scott
you explain civil war i i don't know i i
tend to slightly disagree i think the
new
the new impetus towards societal control
psychological control is to see
if they can get people like aoc who are
conscious and know full well what
they're doing
uh to to vote for them still and i that
you know that's that's my interpretation
like and i don't know about all right i
don't know about aoc
but i know that some of these people
such as pelosi whether elizabeth warren
maybe some of the elders in the democrat
party or in the establishment are fully
aware of the lies that they're telling
you're right
you know i just you know you know what i
was realizing you ever see those uh
scammer emails from like a nigerian
prince yeah people always make fun of
them because the grammar is really bad
that's on purpose no for real so
people assume if this like the scammers
are doing a bad job because they're not
speaking proper english
the reason they do that is because they
don't want to waste time on smart people
aoc is saying dumb things here on
purpose to make sure that smart people
don't waste their time even talking
about what she's doing or engaging her
seriously but all of the dumb people
will fall for it right it's really good
so these old people will get an email
and it'll be like i'm a nigerian prince
send me a check for two thousand dollars
there's typos in it it makes no sense
a person of moderate intelligence says
this makes no sense exit out but if they
sent a really well thought out message a
smart person is going to be like i'm not
sending you any money it's the stupid
people they got to go after yeah so they
want to filter out the smart people and
slowly but surely make people dumber and
dumber so that the pool is bigger yeah
how many people do you think now are
like following this because colbert gets
about two million viewers
mostly not in the key demographic but
you know many how many people do you
think sat down today and they were like
well you know with dred scott um abraham
lincoln issued the emancipation
proclamation so so biden should make a
declaration too and then
how many people do you think are going
to mindlessly repeat the gobbledygook
nonsense she just said way too many
way too many well you i mean if only we
had some kind of disinformation board
you know how to fix yeah if only we had
fact checkers yeah i know who actually
cared about what our politicians said i
know can't i wonder if politifact
mentioned any of this stuff
every now and again she will get fact
checked
keep talking i'm looking up here no no
i'm looking because i'm curious to see
what they'll have to say but
i mean obviously this is not some minor
blunder i don't think they even did it
detail's wrong look they i don't even
think they actually even fact checked
her hold on look at this the last thing
that was from may 9th thanks politifact
she just went on colbert and said a
whole bunch of nonsense that took me
five minutes to debunk not even fine
watches colbert yes two million people
oh wow two million people i still have
corrected i guess he does get views so
he gets a decent it's mostly not in the
key demo but he does get a decent key
demo viewership so first of all it is a
little bit unfair because i've been
reading a lot about the civil war so i
immediately knew these things made no
sense no it's not unfair that you know
facts that she's wrong about no no i'm
i'm saying like i immediately caught it
yeah maybe uh the average person would
not but journalists if they actually
cared i'm not talking about journalism
about regular people
it's it's unfair for me to be critical
of a regular person who didn't know that
and is repeating it to their friends
because they trust her but journalists
should be scrutinizing all of the
politicians the same they don't i just
also like i haven't read about the civil
war since middle school but the claim
that the south the confederacy had
infiltrated the supreme court like
that's literally not how the civil war
worked they they seceded before it was
yeah yeah exactly so it's not possible
well it's fair to say that there were
southern sympathetic justices yeah but
that's not the confederacy stopping abe
lincoln with the supreme court right she
she takes like this tiny morsel of what
what may be factual the the the
perception that the supreme court was
citing in ways that was more favorable
to the south in certain instances like
dred scott but then she turns it into
the confederacy had taken over the
supreme court and was impeding abraham
lincoln yeah with rulings like dred
scott so he had to issue the
emancipation proclamation is just
psychotic garbage doesn't make any sense
yeah
and i want to say i think
you know it's it's funny to me to watch
aoc talk
because
she actually is the example of the true
systemic injustice done on the american
people
the real systemic injustice is to lower
the bar
of intelligence of your leaders
and have you follow them
because you just don't know any better
to create a society of mindless bots
from a ver through a variety of ways and
then give you a puppet leader like aoc
that can in no way properly represent
you in governance or anything else for
that matter that's real systemic
injustice and she gets to run around
with the motif of systemic injustice as
the hallmark of her platform that's a
double cross and triple cross for the
ages it's like a popularity contest i
mean that's what voting is but do you
think it's that we shouldn't have voting
no we definitely should have voting but
i think what's been done to the school
systems in this country or education in
this country or or
communities just in general
was not done
was not organic
it was intentionally done it was
systematically designed
we we like a dumb populace
and that's why i call myself a populist
politically i'm i'm a i'm an america
first christian sovereignness actually
you could say but um i'm a populist
but but you know we do have a populace
right now that's grossly uh
undereducated and misinformed
so it makes it very hard for them to
cast and form votes in our political
system
which is an egregious and egregious
level of moral hazard that comes from
institutions becoming corrupted and in
the west we do place a premium on the
individual
but culture does have an impact on the
individual and we have to understand
both things happen simultaneously but
when the when the establishment gets as
corrupt as it's become now
you get 81 million people voting for a
man who
shouldn't be allowed to drive a car
yeah i think corporations becoming
legally people
severely corrupted our capitalist
institution to the point where now
they're making corporations are making
political statements and that you can't
sue them you can't destroy the people
sue them into oblivion the owners they
just declare it bankrupt and
so nobody fact-checked what she said
like
you're pissed about that well the point
i'm making here is
any conservative politician who even
says anything slightly wrong like ron
desantis was fact checked because i
can't remember exactly what he's talking
about but he said something slightly
imprecise and they're like false false
false we got him we got him we got him
everybody
aoc goes on prime time television at
millions of people strings together
random words and everyone's like i'm
okay with that yeah
you made a good point about aoc and i
think the word is almost controlled
opposition in a sense right she's
supposed to be the outsider candidate
but she really does she does present
everything that the establishment would
like for people to believe i think a
huge part of the problem and i've got on
my soapbox about this a number of times
on the show but we have a culture which
basically places instant gratification
above everything else and even in really
intimate important ways so we've
completely saturated our society with
pornography
and people eat gross fatty foods all the
time and basically the idea is you
shouldn't do things in line with their
purposes you should do things in line
with what brings you the most pleasure
and it trains people to constantly take
the path of least resistance and when
people take the path of release
resistance they're much easier to herd
it's much easier to get people to obey
you when they're going to go along with
what's easiest right before i lose my
temper oh boy i need you to clarify what
you meant by gross and fatty foods okay
so basically and i don't mean to imply
that there's such a thing as anything
that's less healthy than something else
right everyone's healthy all the time
we're all equally healthy all foods are
equally right that cake right there
that this cake is super healthy and
super good for me so do you mean gross
fatty as one thing or do you mean gross
comma fatty gross kama fatty well it's
it's no right avocados are fatty and
they're good for you okay no no okay
i've been doing veggies
fat can be very good for you i'm talking
like the kind of stuff you get at
mcdonald's and i'm talking yeah and it's
fried it's sugary it's salty and it's
okay to have sugary foods every now and
again but if if your if every meal you
eat is this gross stuff that's gonna
weigh you down and destroy your brain
and
it it again it trains you towards doing
something not in line with what makes
sense either for the occasion or for
what you're supposed to be eating
um it it trains you just to pursue
pleasure and so
when other people and one of the things
that is pleasing to us is to fit in with
the crowd
so when other people stand up and and
start promoting bad ideas you're not
going to you're not going to listen to
them so this is this is an idea i've
heard uh i heard from the left they talk
about how
poor people are overweight because they
have worse foods and because garbage
food is cheaper and that's not
necessarily true but it's somewhat true
right and so i was talking to a lefty
friend and here's how they explained it
and i think it's actually a decent point
but needs to be fact checked norman
borlaug was this famous scientist who uh
figured a way to increase crop yield so
that
your typical plant produced way more
like so wheat would produce like four
times the yield all of a sudden there's
way more starch and sugars available for
people but the nutritional density
stayed the same that meant that poor
people were buying the same kind of food
at the same price but there was like
half the amount of folate or thiamine or
whatever in it so they'd have to they
have to buy even more so what happens is
in order to get the same level of
nutritional density they have to eat a
ton of this starchy food and sugary and
fatty food and they gain a bunch of
weight from it right i actually uh that
makes sense to me i'm like why is it
that poor people are overweight and
they're like well the food they eat is
bad and i'm like bro you could buy
tomatoes lettuce and avocado for the
same price as a big mac meal or whatever
and then you real you think about it
it's like
when they're buying grains and breads
and stuff the nutritional density being
lower means they're they're struggling
they're eating a lot more of the same
stuff so it's it's like it's like half
true because i do think people could
make better choices but it still is not
easy for people who don't know why what
they're eating has become bad for them
well there's also this weird thing where
we're obsessed with finding new things
to turn corn into yeah right we're like
what is this food like maybe we could
make it out of corn instead yeah it's
like we have plastic and it's polluting
the world what if we made corn
into plastic
actually a good idea foreign subsidies
yeah it's like are there other ways to
do it thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you